yeah
second half sir tough alright folks
I'm back but before we get to talk to it
I get to tell you that this video is
sponsored by radio versus the Martians
it is a podcast hosted by Mike Gillis
and Casey Doran where they discuss all
manner of geeky material form akira -
Batman - watchman - world Wrestling -
the entire cinematic over of arnold
schwarzenegger podcast LaVista baby is a
sub series on the same podcast feed it's
incredible all things great they have
amazing guests great topics good
discussions it's the McLaughlin group
for nerds radio versus the Martians at
radio versus the Martians calm or
wherever you get your podcasts spy fall
part - it's not as good as the first
part for a couple of reasons but also
for the standard reason that setups are
a little bit easier to sort of really
nail then payoffs are overall though I'm
still pretty positive on it I do have
things that I'm gonna bring up and bits
and pieces across it but um I'll start
positive because I generally speaking I
like to do that
I liked the I actually rather liked the
time hopping and the the people they
encountered I liked that they
encountered a number of real life
figures who I knew very little about and
actually had a lot of fun looking up the
spy in nazi-occupied France the early
inventor of the computer the Charles
Babbage guy like I looked them up like
oh cool and that's like I that's what I
want more of in terms of historical
settings in Doctor Who I want less of
the big celebrity historical figures
like oh I know who that is that give me
somebody on like ooh I'll learn more
them look at stuff up about them and go
oh dang cool so like I like that down
for that I am enjoying this I'm
considerate for you you wouldn't be
washing part two if you didn't see part
one right right at the very least okay
the I like this new master I enjoy his
energy I like that he he's got a little
bit of the more manic energy that kind
of reminds me of John Simm but he's not
quite bouncing off the walls as much I
was I'll admit a little bit nervous
about that especially at the end of spy
fall part one where he seemed very manic
to finally be able to you know say to
the doctor you know I'll figure it out
he what I like here though is there's a
much more of there's a lot more anger in
this master there's I mean the Masters
capable of being very angry but in this
one it seems like a consistent
background level of simmering rage that
gets set off very easily and it doesn't
feel like mood shift on a dime it feels
like whatever veneer was covering over
the rage that is always there falls away
from time to time and that works for me
overall I dug it as far as the aliens
that are kind of invading kind of not I
forget what they were called now you
know chip no I actually think that this
whole two-parter is one of your better
scripts overall but you're still really
kind of crap at coming up with alien
names that I can ever remember anyways
the the whole deal with them the the
idea that the that the earth map that
she thought was a temporal map so wasn't
multiple earth it was earth at different
points in history which was actually
kind of a neat dodge cuz I think a lot
of us had assumed that we were dealing
with what when somebody said multiple
earths we were deal
with multiple dimensions which is also
probably why a fair number of people
thought that these might be the silas
men you know coming through again from
Pete's world so which I mean not say
that would have been bad that would have
been cool I cut but I kind of like that
it kind of nudged us towards a
multiverse situation but then pulled it
back in like no no we're still dealing
with time here which out which also does
have it make a bit more sense that that
the doctor yaz and also the master gets
sort of trapped in that middle space and
things get a little bit wonky when they
get involved because they are time
travelers and it throws stuff off cool
that works um the the stuff with Ryan
Yeahs and Graham it's just it kind of
just fills the space it's alright it's
not bad I think that's part of my
overall thing for why I don't like this
episode as much as the previous one is
that it's lacking the strong forward
momentum because a lot of the stuff
dealing with those three it really does
feel like they just needed something for
them to do and so they just kind of put
them on the run and they have you know
the the guy who the you know the tech
guy I'm I don't know if it's Chibnall if
I'm just having a bad name memory day uh
today but you know II he you know has
them being hunted and all this stuff but
they're not really impacting the plot
they're just kind of running around
staying out of the plots way more than
anything else and I'm not sure what you
could have done with them to have it be
more propulsive to the overall story but
you feel the momentum drop out a little
bit as that stuff goes on the
performances were still good though I
don't I don't think that was an issue I
thought Whitaker had a lot of really
nice moments I liked
I liked her starting in the episode sort
of being in that like my brain as
classified as a synapse forest you know
sort of talking like the companions were
there and and saying you know don't
panic they still will but you save for
yourself as well as my oh yeah cool I
dug that I also kind of like that
well I like it I dislike I liked
realizing kind of in the previous
episode how secretive this doctor has
been which given how much the emphasis
has been on the friend and familial
connection whether companions I found
kind of interesting that she was
arguably more secretive than I would say
possibly any doctor since I Colston and
even that holding on for a longer like
the previous incarnations of the doctor
they've been a bit some of them have
been a little bit slow to admit to your
the history say who they are where they
come from whatnot um but then you've got
some like Matt Smith who that happened
so casually including saying that he
believed at least at the time that he
had wiped out his own people that it
gets brought up by Amy and its
conversation we never actually saw but
it's they just have that kind of
connection where he would have told them
that but for as strong as the connection
between this doctor and the companions
is built up to be she's being very
tight-lipped and very secretive and I
kind of liked that dichotomy so I must
slightly of two minds that she sort of
owns up to so much at the tail end of
this episode that said she's obviously
still holding a lot back and I'm glad
that they retained that feel a bit I do
kind of wish she hadn't just spilled so
many beans there are I didn't mention
this last time because like yeah
whatever but I am starting to get mildly
and
annoyed at things like in spy fall part
one the the doctors a man I got an
upgrade line and the reason I didn't
bring that up last time is because it
was one line I didn't love it but I was
like whatever but then we get into this
one and we add in like Charles Babbage
looking at the silver ladies saying like
most women you know beautiful but
without function or whatever it was he
said like this massive misogynist thing
and I'm like the thing is and here's
what annoys me about this it's not the
sentiment I don't care what annoys me
about is these lines are so ham-fisted
it feels like needlessly poking the bear
especially now in the second series of
Jody Whitaker's doctor where the
Chibnall and all the other writers
regardless of whatever you think about
what they're doing or whether or not
there's a sjw agenda there isn't or
whatever they obviously know that that's
a perception among a certain stripe of
the fandom and I'm I'm not gonna say
that they should or shouldn't be cow
towing or or even acknowledging you know
the part of a fandom that's screaming at
them at all but lines like that feel
like they're poking the bear and they
annoy me because there's no need for
them in the episodes themselves and so
it feels like it's there for no reason
other than to jab at somebody and if it
was better integrated into like the plot
or the themes of the story or
what-have-you
like I just go okay okay you kind of
found a reason to do it maybe I still
wouldn't love it but I probably wouldn't
be complaining about it but as it stands
like they feel very ham fisted Lee
interjected and I'm I'm just kind of
sitting sitting back here going oh so
many people in my comment section gonna
scream about that
that and that and that and the thing is
I don't care but there is it
we're not gaining anything with these
lines and maybe this is me being
completely selfish but just you know how
much crap I'm gonna have to clear out of
my comment section from people putting
those lines in quotes and then swearing
all over the place about it you know
it's it's a headache and I don't see
what we gain out of those and that's not
me saying that like they have to placate
the fans who hate them right now they
don't but you also don't have to
antagonize them either
like what ah again if you're going to do
that justify it better don't just drop
it in like this so the fact that it
happened two episodes in a row that
annoyed me a little bit the other thing
that I'm worried about coming out of
this is huh we're picking up on the
thread of the timeless child and that oh
[Music]
that means the mystery box plot arc for
the series is back and I'm not happy
about that at all I'm so sick of the
series arc being we're just gonna say
this thing early on and repeat it across
the series and not explain what the
flippin heck it is until the last
episode every single series of Doctor
Who except for series 11 has done this
to some degree some more egregious than
others some pulled it off better some
some had a better story they were tying
the mystery box to some just integrated
the stuff better but I'm sick of it
regardless
bad wolf Torchwood mr. Saxon the planets
and the bees disappearing also rose
showing up in in the background of stuff
the cracks in time the the Madame
Kovarian or whatever the heck urn aim is
showing up with them with the panels the
impossible girl Missy in heaven
the the stupid freaking the hybrid the
vaults I'm done enough I am so sick of
this format and more than anything like
I did a video with my host for series 12
and I talked about the things that I
don't want them to just bring all this
stuff back that they left behind and
number one on that list with a bullet
was the mystery box series arcs the
timeless child
maybe it'll still be good maybe it'll
still be interesting but just knowing
how the format's gonna be here's how
they can pleasantly surprise me if we
find out what the heck this thing is by
episode 5 at the latest and then the
back half is dealing with whatever that
information is if they hold off the
reveal of whatever the timeless child is
until the last story and if that's a
two-parter that means either the
second-to-last or the last episode then
I I'm so sick of it
I'm so beyond sick of it and it doesn't
help that they're tying it into this
idea that there's some massive lie about
the time boards from way back in the
very beginning of the like there's a
number of alarm bells
that sets off because you're talking if
this delivers on what it's threatening
to deliver this is massive retcon the
kind that is almost impossible to pull
off cleanly and yo for as mysterious as
the Time Lords are I don't know if
they'll be able to get away with this
too massively rewriting or restructuring
what we know about them and the other
thing I don't like about that is it
sounds reminiscent of the Cartmell
master plan which I also didn't like and
thought was stupid was kind of glad
never got to happen you look that up if
you feel like it but everything you know
is a lie all that line in parallel was
such a red flag the timeless child I'm
not excited to find out I'm just not and
despite my frustration at the tail end
of the SEPA this review I'm still
generally positive about the episode I
think this is still a good general
progress from series 11 I considered
this to be a step up taking this
collectively as a story I consider this
better than the woman who fell to earth
and the ghost monument it is a better
stronger opening it's a tighter script
the issues that I have are for the most
part I'm not gonna say unique to me but
are tied to my own hang-ups as opposed
to things that just feel sloppy which
was kind of an issue with a fair amount
of the scripts in series 11 particularly
the chip no scripts I often felt sloppy
or unpolished or needing one or two more
revisions this didn't feel like it so
this is still a good direction for all
my bitching
I'm just really annoyed that mystery box
arcs are back what are your thoughts on
whatever they are drop something on the
comments let's talk about a bunch of
stuff to do you know the stuff you can
support me on patreon if you are
particularly generous if you want to
help me on a one-time basis I've also
got a PayPal tip jar links are down
there the like subscribe and thumbs up
and all those things go ahead and do
them or don't you don't have to because
at the end of the day you are the
council and I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]